of course uh we are broadcasting here uh
from the
wonderful largo theater in los angeles i
don't know if you listen very
carefully you can hear a high-pitched
drill
outside nothing we can do about it
there's a guy in the alley with a drill
and uh that's the that's the
no it's not raccoons it's a drill it's
it's
andy it's it's ridiculous that we're
living in these conditions but
such is life under covet yes it's true
yeah uh yeah they're digging for oil
back there i don't know what it is
it's literally a guy with a drill
yes yeah
it's a high-pitched wine in the
background and if i wanted a
high-pitched wine i'd go
home
[Laughter]
sometimes you're just a bad person
yeah my wife's lovely and so are my kids
and i don't know why i made that joke
i did it it was cheap yeah it was cheap
and i just went for it
yeah yeah but if i wanted to hi i
pitched wine i'd hang around my house
we got a great show don't go by anything
i just said
the drill in the alley or those cheap
jokes will forte is here on the program
love that guy he's always uh always a
lot of fun and andy i don't know about
you i'm feeling a little more optimistic
about things
oh yeah definitely yeah yeah a lot of
people
say that their categories are coming up
categories are coming up
left and right suddenly a lot of vaccine
is flooding into different states
a lot of people are getting vaccinated
every hour
and it's very exciting time yeah it's
great yeah
yeah just a little tricky for me because
my
specific category hasn't come up yet has
it andy
well i mean i don't know what you mean
because anyone over 50 is eligible in
california now
i i know andy i know that anyone over 50
is uh
eligible i'm talking about my very
specific
category you know the one i'm talking
about don't you
uh i think so you think so you're not
sure
you know what my specific category is um
i i think i know what you're going to
say
i think you know cause i've said it a
bunch of times right maybe you'd like to
remind
people what my specific category is well
you've reminded us so many times
yeah but maybe you'd like to say it do
you think i would like i don't know i
don't really want to
do you think maybe i should say it i can
only say somebody has to say it i would
rather it be you
well i'll say it if you ask me to say
what my specific category is
conan what's your specific uh category
national treasure
that's right so i thought i should check
in on the website and see
if my specific category is eligible
for the uh vaccine that's why i have my
laptop here right right
all right now first things first a
where is it ah here we go h
select one 18 to 49 i wish
49.6 bang
submit we're cooking with gas now andy
yeah
this is exciting use of television time
you bet it is
all right business or industry uh
communications and i.t
no critical manufacturing no
food and agriculture well eventually
arts and media here we go arts and media
here we go
okay occupation
here we go journalist no
graphic designer no sound engineer no
photographer no
editor no writer no national
treasure oh wow yes
click submit and
what's next ah which national treasure
are you all right should be easy barack
obama
no oprah winfrey tom hanks no
yo yo ma no betty white uh-uh
beyonce no meryl streep
no michael jordan dolly parton
no stephen colbert
son of a [ __ ] oh
here we go uh connor o'brien
cellist getting close andy yeah conad
o'brien author no
conan o'brien with a y
philanthropist conan
o'brien come on inventor
come on kahn a no-brain
arborist i'm sorry but it just doesn't
look like you're on there
yeah andy there's a box
labeled other i can type my name in okay
okay
whatever you need yeah no this is gonna
be easy
conan o'brien
and submit
um so how'd it go website's kind of
glitchy
oh i'll check again later yeah
stephen colbert the guy knocks that out
of the park every night what do you want
i want you to get a room okay
when kova's over i just might no all
right well
ask him first he might might not be his
type
damn anyway speaking of helicopters
there's a helicopter now
can you hear that what is it oh the
helicopter's bringing another drill